welcome to this video kinky Lube Luke
Swilley Duke Rivini I don't think so GL
from the Netherlands is always King Luke
so I don't really think at seven okay so
we have ya came we have an ID off let's
see I could go for this given ingen or
form the traditional night off that's a
plane's give inning and fashion maybe
try some less theoretical set up let's
see maybe this is a bit too shaking at
you fire them okay usually it is a good
sign if if a 3 is played ok lets them
get nygean the mix ok
even pawn to h3 can be M can be an idea
this one had weakens f6 I want to at
night h5 g3 not not the most
sophisticated idea but ok let's get the
rook f3 into the action ok should I
should I a sec now the exchange so
probably a valid move maybe he's got too
much attack going okay that time I had I
had played for this so let's let's let's
suck of the exchange I wonder should I
take I could also think about taking
with the bishop try to establish a
knight on e4 knight takes Bishop takes
Bishop takes like he's very good with e5
ok but hard to to to evaluate in in a
blitz blitz game situation yeah d 5 you
know he's got he's got Knight d2 maybe
just come in here yeah let's keep keep
some pressure on the long diagonal may
be here Bishop g7 rook GA James not
particularly great my idea was wants to
try to make sure that this this Bishop
stays there not just here yeah d 5 why
not d 5 is a good spot
yeah this is better can i play look aged
62 g six maybe one night the night let's
improve the night why not knight to e
492 h5 that's a good squares threatening
g3 and intending to go to g threatening
at c3 and attending to go to g3 tried
for g5 yeah while position probably
probably quite a promising for black but
not at all easy to play and I can take
here
yeah i'm not sure that you really
threaten something so just protect this
and
yeah okay needed to do something because
with with some non-committal moves white
was just busted so he he tries with what
sacking something I've got 22 pieces for
the for the rook already and winning
structure everything but still you can
teach can try with counter sex okay it
looks it looks like i'm having a
harmonious position
threatening on f6 I kept it takes I
should be five check forgotten about
this check
ah this wasn't necessary at all check
yeah it's a it's tricky to defend I mean
just just not easy
yeah i know is playing good moose I
playing like I don't know what I don't
know how to call it but just highly very
very badly and now he's playing well
yeah black resin recent it was probably
like minus five or something hard too
hard to get any of his moves it's just
completely outplayed it's about minus
five yeah it's still tricky i mean i'm
down on 130 I should I should sue in but
it's a guy to get get confused check
check up to hear it was it was still
winning but here it gets tricky this
does not win king h5 is the rightness
you know King age five good luck with
finding that and this time situation
check it's still a draw up to this point
yeah yeah yeah it's just it's just over
i mean i can i can i can play that even
but okay it's basically all moves are
winning but maybe I should I should just
take you three here and I just simplify
the position this Bishop is more
dangerous than the rooks are yeah this
is this I should do that really the king
is also quite safe this is a much better
choice then what I did besides Bishop b6
which wins outright but yeah this is
already a bit tricky in a blitz game and
yeah not to satisfying if you play
against GM and you really gives you
everything to to win whether you really
should win alright thanks for watching